the elgato 4k60s plus aims to be the
gaming content creator's best friend it
features an x-gen encoding chip built
right in true lag-free pass-through and
the ability to record 4k 60 frames per
second gameplay footage with hdr10
support anytime anywhere all into a
single sd card what's up fellow geeks
zacky here from geek culture back for
another video this time we are gonna
take a look at the elgato 4k60s plus
like many things that gone in our
channel gaming videos are indeed an
integral part of it in a traditional
sense capture cards have always been
more of a peripheral than an actual
device there simply wasn't a solution
for capturing 4k footage on the go or
having to email or share massive raw
unedited files which made capturing
gameplay incredibly inconvenient and
impractical and now with next-gen
consoles being able to push out native
4k at high refresh rates it seems to us
that there needs to be an easier way to
record gameplay hassle-free one very
noticeable problem for us is that we
struggle with the ps5 webm video file
format we've been using the ps5 in build
recording system and this web and video
file format just makes it extremely hard
to work with on editing speeds like
premiere pro even with third party
plugins the webm file format still
causes crashes on premiere pro and this
makes it such a hassle for video editors
like myself
so i needed to find an alternative
solution for this problem and that's
where the elgato 4k60s plus came into
the picture so with that being said why
don't we unbox this and check it out but
before we continue with this review do
consider subscribing and smash the bell
icon so you can be notified whenever we
upload new videos
yeah
so when we first got the elgato 4k 60s
plus we were surprised by the size of
the packaging i mean
if you look at it up close it's actually
pretty large when you open it up and
slide it out of the box you'll be
greeted by a brief quick start guide
that tells you all about the functions
of the capture card and how to set it up
and right out of the box you can see
that this is the elgato 4k60s plus
you can see some very nice patterns over
here as well as the elgato logo
obviously and facing the back you can
see that we have a few
ports
over here starting with the hdmi in and
out ports as well as two usbc ports one
is for power and one is to link up to
your pc and moving to the front of the
panel you can see that we have the sd
card slot as well as the touch
capacitive record button
as well as the 3.5 mm line in out of the
box you also got your main power supply
along with a slew of international
adapters
let's say all the adapters are simple
snap on and snap off function
like shell
which makes this whole package great for
portability and lastly in the box you
get three cables one being the hdmi 2.0
cables and your two usbc cables right
now the best part about this that all
the cables have a nice premium feel to
them and they're even gold plated so you
know you're getting the good stuff here
guys and that's all there is to it
honestly it's really meant to be a
standalone game capture card device so
once you set all of this up you're good
to go now it is recommended that you use
an sdxc card that being said agato
recommends an sd card that has at least
a uhs class 3 or a v30 now it is also
important that you get an sd card that
has a higher storage capacity we're
talking about at least 128 gigabytes to
256 gigabytes you could also use a
microsd card with an adapter that has
the recommended class and storage
capacity of course you could also use up
to one terabyte of storage capacity but
over one terabytes have not been tested
by agato and it may not work so you
should be able to get six to seven hours
of gameplay footage at 4k 60fps on a
single
gigabyte sd card and you can either
format it to fat32 or exfat keep in mind
that fat32 is going to split your files
into every four gigabytes or if you're
like me and prefer to just have one
chunky file then exfat is the way to go
so now the beauty of the elgato 4k 60s
plus is that it's a standalone game
capture device
this means that you don't have to plug
into a pc so all you need to do is plug
it in pop an sd card hit record on the
touch sensor
and you're good to go it's easy as that
and if you're a streamer and you want to
use a pc you can do that too you can
wire your 4k 60s plus with the
additional usb c to usb a cable you can
record it standalone on your pc and
capture gameplay footage direct to the
sd card alternatively you can use the
4k60s plus with third-party broadcasting
software like obs and xsplit so you have
some flexibility there
now one good thing about the 4k60s plus
is that it not only records in 4k 60fps
but in hdr as well
so if you're playing hdr you have the
ability to do that
it basically records whatever you put
into it so if you're playing hdr it
records in hdr you also have the option
to record an sdr so you can still use
this to record 1080 or even 2k on pc it
is fully supported now we've been using
the s plus as a standalone with the ps5
as both a way of recording gameplay
footage to an sd card and as a pass
through device to play games on the tv
and doing either of those things we
absolutely had no hitch and in fact it
actually works better than we expected
it to now it's worth noting that this
has a leg free pass through feature if
you've just connected it to a tv or a
bigger screen but other than that well
it's not really lag free while live
streaming
so you will need to offset that in your
live stream software so that you can be
in sync with your webcam and your audio
now another neat feature about this
device is that you're able to control
the bitrate and recording settings such
as recording it at raw 4k
now it really goes a little more into
the technical side of things where you
actually have to edit a settings.txt
file in the sd card itself
which agato automatically places on the
sd card so you're probably asking
yourself what happens when you're
recording and reach the end of the card
capacity so the 4k 60s plus will leave
about 90 megabytes or so free so it can
properly finish off the file afterwards
the recording simply stops but it will
not be corrupted so heads off to the
folks at elgato for really creating this
very neat feature the file size is
manageable and editing suites like
premiere pro works very smoothly on it
not to mention that all the gameplay
footage you're seeing in the background
are all shot in 4k 60fps
so it's really a fantastic product
coming from gato of course this comes at
a very hefty price tag of 400 us dollars
which might sway some buyers but this is
definitely a godsend when it comes to
live streamers and content creators who
want to bring their capture capabilities
on the road without having to lug around
pcs or figure out wires and splitters
now the 4k 60s plus is definitely the
best and the best in creating gaming
content and perhaps more its standalone
performance is perhaps what's considered
well at least for us it's the most ideal
option that gives you the tools and
power you need for its convenience size
and weight and two is standalone
recording without needing a pc
makes this probably one of the best
capture cards money can buy so yeah
that's it for this video we hope you
enjoyed this one and if you found it
helpful do give us a thumbs up what do
you think about the 4k60s plus and
perhaps other gacho products let us know
in the comments below and if you haven't
already do consider subscribing and
smashing the bell icon so you can be
notified every time we upload a new
video
yeah
until then this is zaki signing off
adios muchachos
[Music]
[Music]